we are all of course concerned because
conflicts so situations that can evolve
in that region will have implications
for all NATO allies and all Alliance the
British Foreign Secretary me hunt Alice
I'm meeting said that there is a risk of
a conflict happening through an error of
judgment through a mistake I mean would
you share that assessment that when we
have military forces as we see in that
region is always a risk for
miscalculations that's exactly why it is
important that we come that that that
all involved convey very clear messages
to avoid enemies calculations and I
think also that's what the United States
is doing exactly it's doing now but
again this is a u.s. decision in u.s.
deployment so it's not for me sectarian
or NATO to speak on behalf of United
States yeah but I mean you know I both
know that when the United States decides
to do something militarily
in a big way around the world it does
tend to drag in NATO States if not
actually NATO under NATO flag I mean
NATO States become heavily involved and
dazzles the reason why I welcome that
the United States is consulting closely
with NATO allies on different levels in
different ways and I just wondered
though some where we sit you see we look
at we we we know what goes on in terms
of military assets that can send to the
region we see the rhetoric coming out of
Tehran and Washington I just wonder as a
as a man who is you know plugged into it
honor on a completely different level a
much higher level if you have faith in
what you're hearing from one of your
major partners in terms of this risk
that is coming out of Iran right now as
opposed to the more general as idiy
what is of concern for all need allies
is what Iran has been doing for many
many years trying to destabilize the
region supporting different tightest
organizations and also both the missile
program and the nuclear ambitions of
Iran and yes there are disagreements on
the Iran nuclear deal between NATO
allies but all agree that it is
important to prevent the ground from
developing nuclear weapons so what about
the Iran nuclear deal I mean I think
most will agree is not perfect but of
course we have this disparity in
views in that France Germany the United
Kingdom and others think that it is the
best deal that you'll get in in the in
the circumstances do you agree with that
as I said that the challenge when it
comes to the Iran nuclear deal for NATO
is that we have not been able to have a
unified position we welcome the deal as
NATO back in 2015 when the deal was
signed because we at that time assess
that this would help to reduce the risk
for people they were like lead over Iran
developing nuclear weapons we don't have
that in common position today everyone
can see in the public debate that there
are different views between NATO allies
and in particular the United States have
different you done
for instance European allies have on
this issue that's a fact
I regret that we don't have a
composition but that's a fact Huawei is
one of the main security issues
currently dominating headlines here in
the UK what is your position on Huawei
and the threat or perhaps not a threat
that it poses to Western society as the
question of infrastructure
telecommunications infrastructure 5g is
of great importance for all NATO allies
it's partly because it will affect how
we organize our societies in the future
it will affect all critical
infrastructure and it will also have
security implications at the same time
these these are national decisions and
NATO allies are now addressing or or or
or discussing the requirements they will
have for 5g what matters for NATO is
that we make sure that we have secure
communications that we have secured
telecommunications and infrastructure
and that's reason why we also have a
discussion now in NATO on how to make
sure that yeah also in the world with
more and more 5g that we are able to
have secure and resilient
telecommunications infrastructure and as
the Secretary General of NATO are you
confident
Huawei is secure or do you have your
doubts like the Americans have been very
efficient several allies have raised
their concerns and have expressed doubts
but there is now an ongoing discussion
in different NATO allied countries and
between NATO allies I welcome that
because this is part of a technical
issue there are some political aspects
and is also quite a question about how
you manage risks and therefore we need
open discussion we need analysis by
different than to analyze to try to
develop a best possible approach